So in this study there's far more concordance in
the monozygotic twins than there is in the dizygotic
twins. Which indicates a strong but not complete genetic
influence. Now I know we've been over it a couple
times now, but I really hope you understand this
important connection. When you have a strong correlation or concordance
with monzygotic twins, and you don't see as much
with dizygotic twins, that's when you know there's a stronger
genetic component. When the monozygotic twins and the dizygotic
twins are closer together in their concordance or correlation rates,
that's when you can't say it's because of genetics.
And that's more to do with the environment. Now I
use numbers from one particular study of bipolar disorder,
but there are multiple different studies out there. And these
numbers can change over time so don't take these
as a fact of bipolar. This is, this being the
final say or anything. Science constantly re-evaluates its
conclusions based on the given data. And this could
change in the future, but for our purposes
right here, this study indicates a strong genetic influence.